good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i want to hear an
amazing story
so as a child growing up in south
central los angeles larry elder had a
secret
elder's father who was a janitor was
black so was elder's mother so we're 80
percent of the people in their
neighborhood and to all appearances
larry elder seemed black too
that's what the people around him always
assumed
little did they know that this child of
south central apparently an
african-american in good standing was in
fact a secret agent working on behalf of
global white supremacy what an
assignment
a white supremacist in south central
imagine that and yet for more than 50
years no one had any idea this was going
on larry elder spent decades in the
public eye as a radio show host and not
one person during that time guessed the
terrible truth
and then last month the crack
investigative team at the los angeles
times finally broke this story quote
larry elder is the black face of white
supremacy read a headline in the
newspaper you've been warned
busted
so how did the la times discover this
well it took real journalism there were
none of the usual telltale signs nobody
caught larry elder re-segregating water
fountains or burning across on
somebody's lawn no
it was far more subtle than that and
much more dangerous
instead larry elder publicly insisted on
exercising his constitutional rights and
then running for political office
worse and more damning larry elder
criticized the leadership of the
democratic party of california he even
went so far is to run against the
sitting governor gavin newsom and that's
how you know that larry elder is a white
supremacist he challenged an incompetent
liberal white guy who is personal
friends with nancy pelosi and that
ladies and gentlemen is what racism is
the question is now that we know this
can larry elder win anyway we'll find
out in three weeks if larry elder is
elected he will not only be the first
black governor of california he will
also be the most popular statewide
official in recent memory
that's the interesting thing for a
purported democracy california has a
long history of electing people that
polls show just about everyone who
actually lives there hates
it's an awfully strange kind of
democracy that way dianne feinstein for
example has represented the state of
california in the u.s senate for nearly
30 years and yet
her approval rating is just 35 percent
yet somehow she keeps her job anyway how
kamala harris did the same thing
when kamala harris ran for president
only seven percent of california's
democratic voters said they supported
her
and that makes you wonder how harris got
elected in the first place to anything
but don't ask
a question like that would be what we
call the big lie
so shut up and accept it
the interesting thing is that california
voters don't technically have to accept
it because a century ago voters in that
state amended the constitution to allow
the recall of demonstrably awful
politicians who'd unfortunately taken
office so let's say you had a pompous
low iq governor who was totally
incapable of managing his own empty
personal life but at the same time who
for his own perverse reasons seemed
totally intent on destroying the entire
state
what would you do with the guy like that
well on september 14th of this year next
month california voters will have the
chance to fire him
they have a recall option if a majority
decides to recall gavin newsom then the
replacement candidate who gets the most
votes will become the governor and as of
tonight that is likely to be larry elder
larry elder could actually win
so no wonder the la times is so upset no
wonder they dispatched a crack
investigative team to discover he was
secretly a white supremacist
even dim old gavin newsom who in the
best of times seems only vaguely aware
of his surroundings who has what they
say in the military knows situational
awareness even that man dopiel gavin
newsom has finally started to figure out
he's in very serious trouble
i think this is important to know larry
elder's running away with this on the
other side
i just hope folks i want to level 7th
what
could happen on election day if we don't
turn out
in historic numbers to vote no on this
recall think about the judges he'd
appoint
who would he have appointed to replace
kamala harris in the u.s senate how
would that impact the director of this
country
what would
this mean
the future of the democratic party
oh did you see the fear and his botox
dies
that ladies and gentlemen was a cry for
help and guess who heard it oh the media
in california they worked for him and so
they immediately got to work here's an
actual line from a story produced by the
so-called news division of the la times
quote
one issue was elder's pronunciation of
the n-word he used an exaggerated tone
enunciating the er at the end of the
word rather than using the a
pronunciation which is more commonly
accepted among and used by black people
studies have shown
studies have shown really
studies done by which researchers in
which social science laboratories and
who exactly is funding these studies on
the n-word and how it's pronounced
unfortunately times did not explain any
of that there was no footnote to the
story instead the paper just kept going
it dispatched one of its crack
investigative reporters over to msnbc
the natural venue
to report their findings
he says he doesn't believe sanctuary
laws or citizenship for dreamers um
should be happening he's against
in-state tuition health care and
driver's licenses for the undocumented
how serious
are the chances that this guy could be
the next governor of california
well it's very serious because it's
possible that the you know the majority
of the people who are going to turn out
are the people who are excited by larry
elder's brand of you know
extreme far right uh
beliefs and and he just represents an
incredible threat to immigrant rights
and racial justice the immense progress
that california has made on these issues
and it would set a
catastrophic
precedent that would reverberate across
the country and it's ironic this is a
black man it just goes to show you that
it is true that even people of color can
be influenced by white supremacist
narratives and fall victim to it right
that's got to be the greatest clip ever
played on cable television ever
so here you have the lady from the la
times explaining to the harvard race
lady that the real problem is that
voters might be too excited to vote for
larry elder they might be psyched about
their own leader and that would set a
terrible precedent oh yes is the harvard
race of the absolutely here's a black
guy who's been brainwashed by the white
man
and voters might like it
that's a threat this democracy thing is
a threat
cnn is deeply concerned as well so cnn
mobilized its goons too a crack unit it
describes as the leading investigation
team for the social media mobile
generation
if you can't even imagine so they
dispatched this team what did the team
find well they found more thought crimes
for example and we're quoting here
larry elder
even has challenged mainstream orthodoxy
on subjects like violence against women
can you imagine
larry elder quote even challenged
orthodoxy
yes even orthodoxy and not only that cnn
also discovered that quote elder has
long relished making provocative
comments in his time as a radio show
host
wait provocative comments too when will
this nightmare end
it's starting to sound like larry elder
might not be just like everyone else in
politics and that's disgusting it is as
the l.a times informed us a terrifying
trend
the other hand it's entirely possible
trying to stay open-minded here that
some voters in california
might like it
why would they like it possibly because
the people who currently run their state
have destroyed it completely
to name just one among many examples
those people have arbitrarily released
more than 75 000 prison inmates
including violent felons now the point
of this of course was something called
equity
never described but frequently on
display what was the result of this well
here's the result watch
out in the open free-for-alls like the
one that happened at this walgreens on
monday have spiked over the past year
with brazen thieves clearing shelves of
food cosmetics and over-the-counter
drugs that are often resold on the
street home depot shared pictures of
recent busts of entire warehouses filled
to the rafters with stolen drills nail
guns and other tools a witness captured
this wild scene on monday as a crowd of
thieves stormed neiman marcus
no one was hurt but the group made off
with handbags and other designer goods
that will most likely be resold online
where organized retail crime is thriving
so they never do define equity do they
the new president used the word equity
more than any other word in his
inaugural but what is it oh that's what
it is equity is stealing it's ripping
off power tools from home depot it's
taking handfuls of lipstick from
walgreens it's stealing
so where do we get here how do we get
here well this is what happens when you
let the ideologues on twitter control
your state
by the way the social media
revolutionaries are not simply in charge
of criminal justice policy in california
they've also taken complete charge of
the energy grid
right
gavin newsom has ordered the state to
transition to something called
renewables another term that's never
defined
in nine years by 2030. what's the result
of this well it's a lot like what's
happening to walgreens the lights don't
work the air conditioning has gone dead
california frequently runs out of power
it's zimbabwe on the pacific oh don't
say that tough it is
and everybody who lives there knows it
unless you're rob breiner and you've got
your own generator
but gavin newsom doesn't care he just
keeps destroying california why does he
hate california so much in his first
year as governor homelessness people
living outside defecating on the
sidewalk jumped seven percent statewide
in la county it jumped 13 in one year
have you been there recently
well three years ago an official from
the un did show up he came to san
francisco that's the city that gavin
newsom once ran as mayor the city he
promised to rid of homelessness make it
possible for women to jog in golden gate
park again but he didn't so the u.n
officials showed up clearly he's seen a
lot of bad places he said california was
so bad that what he saw quote
constitutes cruel and inhuman treatment
and is a violation of multiple human
rights was he overstating the case
here's what it looks like
this isn't camping
these are homes you see fighting
guns knives
fires drug use day in and day out you
don't realize sometimes what you're
living in the middle of until you see
some
a video
and you think wait a minute that's where
i live there was a cleanup today so how
often do they do this clinton oh this is
the first one in months
this is not humane this is not
compassionate if i was the councilman i
would be down here right now man talking
to you talking to these people saying
what are we going to do about this man
the city councilman has allowed them not
to have a rock bottom
oh did you see that racist lady at the
end complaining that there are mentally
ill drug addicts right in front of her
store destroying the city another white
supremacist so why is this happening
well
you get what you put up with that's the
first thing to note the second thing to
note is that california may be the only
place in america where homelessness
actually is a connection to housing
prices that's not true in most places it
is true in california
median home prices in the state of
california are now north of 800 000
first time it's happened ever
a lot of reasons this is happening
massive foreign investment from china is
one of them no one's even bothering to
stop that because they're taking payoffs
from the real estate developers but the
bottom line is that normal people can't
afford housing what has gavin newsom
done to help them not one thing who is
he helping well he's spending his time
and your money awarding among other
things free health care to hundreds of
thousands of foreign nationals who snuck
in we used to call them illegal aliens
they're four nationals with foreign
passports but they're getting free
health care
from you it's like a joke but it's not a
joke it's happening in our biggest state
so next month's recall may be the last
chance to save the state of california
and you should want that because it
matters because it's our country but
it's also about something bigger than
just one state this recall is a test of
our democracy the question is do
elections still have meaning are voters
still allowed to choose their own
leaders or does the l.a times get to do
that does the party apparatus get to do
that do we have any power at all as
citizens or they're going to steal it
from us
if the answer is they're going to steal
it from us then we're in trouble
once citizens conclude that their votes
are meaningless they quickly become
radical democracy is the safety relief
valve that keeps our society placid
but when people think it's fake they go
bonkers because they have no option they
have no power they have nothing to lose
so it's in the interest of all of us
that the state of california conducts a
free and fair election next month yes
with outside election observers u.n
you're welcome too
why
because they're indications that it
won't be free and fair just yesterday
police in torrance california announced
they had found hundreds of stolen recall
ballots in someone's car what were the
ballots doing there oh we don't know
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else